bonjour ou la table je merci d'être avec
nous aujourd'hui sur rt france alors à
nestea international met donc les
autorités à libanaise d'empêcher le bon
déroulement de l'enquêté sur l'explosion
du port de beyrouth
quelle est votre analyse justement en
fait c'est vrai nous croyons tous que la
destination ibanez n'ira pas très loin
car la plupart des responsables bien qui
sont demandées devant le juge ne
voudrais pas à comparaître
et effectivement le peuple libanais
commencent à s'impatienter et nous
demandons une investigation
internationale
et pourquoi pas un tribunal
international vu que l'ampleur de ce
crime qui est sur les chaînes
internationales un crime contre
l'humanité france quels sont les
responsables selon vous pourquoi le
gouvernement d'assad ya parvient-il à
échapper aux poursuites car la plupart
d'entre eux ont la couverture politique
de football a car ces décès de grosses
têtes de sécuritaire le grosses têtes
sécuritaire qui appartiennent à
plusieurs partis politiques parce qu'ils
appartiennent c'est des gens qui sont
des employés chez les partis politiques
et en l'occurrence si le hezbollah en ce
qui concerne le port de beyrouth et le
stockage des armes de l'ammonium qui
était qui n'est plus un secret d'une
investigation française et d'autres
investigations
ce sont des âmes qui étaient utilisés
pour la guerre en syrie deux ans
stocker ce genre d'armes presque
nucléaire entre les maisons et causé
tant de morts étant de descriptions à sa
seule demanderez l'arrestation immédiate
de ces gens là ou bien au moins la
décence de quitter leur poste ils n'ont
pas quitté leur poste ils s'en fichent
du juge ne veulent pas comparaître
devant lui et jusqu'à présent jusqu'à
nouvel ordre
ils ont l'appui de certains certains
partis politiques
lucette vu l'ampleur de ce qui s'est
passé la colère des gens la colère des
des parents des victimes des familles
des victimes ces gens là à risque lynché
dans la rue ou bien elle risque très
grave
justement vous vous ralliez vous parliez
de la rue je me permets de vous
interrompre quelques instants on a
entendu la colère des libanais 1 depuis
quelques semaines maintenant quant à la
lenteur justement des décisions quant à
ce quant à cette explosion
on connaît également le contexte un
actuellement économique politique au
liban
est-ce qu'on peut assister dans ce grand
contexte un soulèvement populaire
durement demain ça va être une très
grande journée une énorme journée quand
bien jamais eu autant je crois
est-ce que ça va s'arrêter le soir parce
qu'ils allaient cérémonie à 6 heures je
ne le pense pas la colère va augmenter
ces gens là qui ont été désignés par le
juge comme des suspects et qui refusent
de comparaître devant lui et risque
vraiment très grave
la colère n'a va continuer à monter non
seulement à cause de la crise économique
financière est ce que c'est
ses complices ils sont tous là la classe
politique c'est une étude classe
verhulst pervers incapable lâche indigne
d'être d'être dans les postes alors il
risque très très grave parce que la
colère des gens commencent vraiment par
part augmenté de façon alarmante
alors y aura plus de la manifestation
un paisible comme on le disait tout à
l'heure les ong human rights watch a
recommandé à la mise en place justement
d'une enquête d'une mission
d'investigation indépendante de l'onu
même si cette mission voit le jour qu'en
attendez vous nous attendons au moins
l'arrestation de certaines personnes qui
ont été jugés ou bien harry j'ai désigné
par le juge libanais qui qui
contrairement à ce que tout le monde
pense et finalement on a eu un juge qui
a le courage et qui est en fin de compte
il est en danger de mort parce que ces
gens là ont tué ont déjà tué d'autres
personnes ils ont ce jeu jusqu'à présent
insiste insiste à ce que justice soit
faite
s'il n'acceptait pas de comparaître
devant lui mais je pense qu'une
commission internationale avec l'appui
des nations unies pourraient
probablement les arrêter et commençait
sérieusement à son investigation au
tamis d'investigation est ce que la
france encore une influence au liban et
est ce que
justement la france pourrait être
intervenir dans ce sujet précis sur ce
sujet précis jusqu'à présent de 1 la
france la france
la visite du président macron la veille
le lendemain de l'explosion à apaiser
les gens un petit peu quand il a promis
que dans quelques jours la vérité sera
faite et rien n'a été fait on le savait
déjà
alors aujourd'hui les gens ont de moins
de moins en moins conscience
ils veulent des actions et non pas des
paroles la france a promis des sanctions
contre contre les politiciens libanais
nous l'espérons bien et il va falloir
que la france agissent très vite
l'europe agissent très vite pour que
l'on recommence à avoir confiance dans
un partenaire traditionnel historique
je parle du peuple libanais qui a de la
france viennent l'europe mais nous
aimons bien voir des actions et non pas
des paroles et jusqu'à présent il ya eu
des paroles
merci beaucoup la table d'avoir été avec
nous aujourd'hui sur arte frange
rappelle que vous êtes un analyste
politique merci beaucoup